peu à peu
[Musique]
bonsoir cette camionnette ne vous est
peut-être pas d'inconnus
en effet c'est celle que conduit victor
lanoux dans un téléfilm co produit et
diffusé sur france 3 intitulée louis la
brocante aujourd'hui une équipe de rené
de première et seule et dieu et vous y
emmène conte comment c'était très bien
pour ce troisième épisode de louis la
brocante tournis à grigny près de lyon
victor lanoux a dû apprendre à faire des
barbapapas les péripéties du brocanteur
ton en effet cette fois ci autour d'un
vieux manège que le héros accepte de
récupérer et qui contient bien des
secrets
victor lanoux qui incarne le rôle-titre
de ce téléfilm s'est beaucoup attaché à
son personnage c'est un personnage
profondément injuste profondément humain
en même temps il a une
il est malin il est coquin il a il a des
comme ça des des petites pointes marron
il n'hésite pas à prendre du fric là où
il y en a par contre il va le donner ce
qu'ils n'ont pas c'est c'est une forme
de come ca de chevaliers modernes
un personnage qui a su séduire aussi les
français puisque le deuxième épisode du
téléfilm diffusé en octobre dernier a
rassemblé plus de 30 % des
téléspectateurs devant son record
d'audience france 3 qui coproduit le
téléfilm à hauteur de 80% a décidé de
continuer la série
le tournage du quatrième épisode
débutera le 12 avril
l'écriture du cinquième est déjà en
cours et en l'an 2000 trois nouveaux
numéros devrait voir le jour pour
expliquer un tel succès on parle bien
sûr la notoriété de victor lanoux
mais aussi du thème général du téléfilm
la brocante aussi s'est associé au passé
que le passé en cette fin de millénaire
c'est bien à quoi le passé ça veut dire
des bonnes choses
une bonne table en temps avec de l'an
caustique ça nous rappelle les grands
mères le vieux manège des sujets
d'aujourd'hui le prochain sujet sur le
verre qu'on souffle enfin tout ça nous
ramène à des choses qui fleure bon le
bon souvenir le tournage de ce 90
minutes est prévu sur 21 jours mais le
téléfilm ne sera prêt à être diffusés
qu'à la mi juin la diffusion de cet
épisode est prévu pour la rentrée
prochaine et pour tenir ces délais il
faut que la machine de production soit
bien ville est alors pour ce faire une
équipe d'une cinquantaine de personnes
investissent les lieux le temps du
tournage dsit de l'envers du décor il
est 7h30 soit trois heures à peine avant
le premier clap premiers arrivés sur les
lieux la régie qui s'activent pour
préparer le café finaliser les décors
installés maquilleuse et habille eu la
première fois que l'équipe est entré
dans cette maison il y faisait moins 2
degrés c'était il ya quatre semaines
lors du repérage
depuis les autorisations de tournage ont
été obtenus le chauffage et le téléphone
mise en place on n'attend plus que
l'arrivée des techniciens du son et de
l'image
mais le travail de la régie n'est pas
fini pour autant même si le travail
principal de la régie c'est avant le
tournage même pendant le tournage
pendant les heures de plateau on est
constamment sollicité puisqu'il ya
toujours une demande particulière de la
mise en scène qui en fait qui doit se
régler au jo au jour le jour à la minute
même avant mon esprit il arrive quelque
part par là des bouffes avec une échelle
9h le réalisateur maurice cridland
explique aux équipes le découpage plan
par plan des séquences de la journée
quand il ya un dialogue entre vue et la
gamine qui est en train de ranger la
pièce love deezer les acteurs sont
habillés maquillés derniers réglages
les clappes peuvent être lancés
en moyenne plus de 4 minutes utiles sont
tournés chaque jour ici une performance
sachant qu'au cinéma cette durée ne
dépasse pas 2 minutes
le défi d'un tournage du téléfilm c'est
donc avant tout de bien gérer le temps
sans trop faire de conception c'est
l'émoi on prend plus de temps pour
arriver à la perfection comme le
souhaite le réalisateur droite et les
fausses aille très très vite donc on a
faut que tout soit bien préparée avant
pour aller très très vite quand on veut
faire beaucoup de cascades ou coup de
c'est compliqué parce qu'on n'a pas le
temps
le plan de travail établi par le premier
assistant doit donc anticiper maximum
les journées de tournage tout est
notifié les heures de repas aux
accessoires utiles en passant par les
horaires de coucher de soleil est
essentielle pour les tournages en
extérieur
chaque soir après la dernière scène la
pellicule est envoyé à paris pour être
développé
elle est ensuite des rochers puis monte
à france 3 lyon un travail de deux mois
réservé aux équipes de la post
production
[Musique]